hello everyone and welcome back to binge
battle i am your host mark ellis and
here at rotten tomatoes we celebrate all
things television movies everywhere in
between
and now it's a goodbye of sorts because
better call saul the show that we really
didn't know that we needed after
breaking bad suddenly worked its way
into our hearts and once again
we say goodbye to saul to the whole cast
and crew there of that wonderful show as
the final season has just ended but now
that means that we get to celebrate the
greatness that we got to see
particularly in that final season that's
what today's binge battle is going to be
focused on the final season of better
call saul as we do with every show i'm
going to let you all know that the
spoiler warning is in effect so if
you've not yet seen all of better call
saul especially the final season really
you haven't seen breaking bad you might
want to hit pause on this go check out
two of arguably the greatest shows of
all time and then come on back and enjoy
our spirited debate that we have with
two expert panelists who also happen to
be some dear friends i'll remind you
guys you can check out
rottentomatoes.com for your hub all
things tv and movies and some binge
battles so here we go with our topic
today the final season of better call
saul introducing first fighting out of i
believe new york today but he's known to
get into a van or a winnebago from time
to time and fly all around this galaxy
you know him from pretty much it and
there's stellar work on youtube and
other places he is eric striffler
sir welcome you're actually you look
rested you look like you're in a house
with a roof over your head how does that
feel yeah well now i'm disappointed of
all the times for me not to be in a
vehicle that i live in i should have
been for the rv from breaking bad i
should have done that today but what are
you gonna do i didn't think of it
uh eric let me let me ask you this
because i know you do spend a lot of
time on the road traveling but when
better call saul let's go back to the
beginning of better call saul when it
was announced that there was going to be
this prequel follow-up sort of to
breaking bad did you think it had a
chance at working or did you think uh
we're really just tugging on this utter
for its last drop
you know it's funny because we were
still doing our weekly show pretty much
it the friday show and that was one of
the topics i'm almost positive that was
like the thumbnail for that episode was
about the announcement so i could go
back and find out but i i almost i want
to guess
i think our opinion was probably
nervous like is this necessary breaking
bad was so good could this and you know
people always say like oh it's not going
to taint it you still have breaking bad
but it does you know what i mean it can
taint the legacy a little bit right uh
like a reboot or a late sequel it
doesn't you know change the original but
it kind of does so i think we were
probably nervous for it um and rightly
so who knew that that could possibly
work
yeah really the fact that we're having
not one but two binge battles based on
better call saul this season means i
think it worked okay and a returning
favorite to binge battle i know that
eric knows him pretty well there's some
shared history with pretty much it there
we had him on debating the entirety of
better call saul up to the last season
because we had witnessed it and he's
back to defend his love for now the
final season you also know him from the
friends per second podcast and that is
jake baldino jake it's friends per
second uh how many friends can you make
in one second or one minute not a lot
it's really hard actually uh we only
have three
technically three and uh that's about
all i can get really thanks for having
me
i'm glad you brought the loser back
though because i mean like makuga
crushed me during that that last one uh
thanks for thanks for dragging me out he
was very excitable and uh we love having
you back because you obviously bring the
world's biggest hot dog background and
you also have strong feelings about
breaking bad and better call sauce so i
asked eric and i'd already asked you on
the last episode about when better call
saul was announced but going into this
final season we'll get into all the
particulars of it but were you more
excited or were you just more sad that
you had to say goodbye
i was sad because
i it's like the first time i've had that
old television feeling in a while where
i was gripped
week to week and like it was like back
to like the you know the corny phrase
the water cooler discussions like i was
getting that again but it was just like
me and my dog discussing it but still it
was it's for so long
we've had this like week to week thing
and something to think about and
something to digest and it was like damn
good prestige television so
i'm sad to see it go
uh there is nothing wrong with talking
to your dog shout out to draco and molly
the wonder dogs that help make this show
go and with that we are going to get
kicked off here with binge battle here's
a refresher as to how it works we have
four rounds possibly five if we end up
having a tie breaker need there you each
get one opening statement that can be up
to a minute long then you'll get a
rebuttal which is 30 seconds or less and
then you have your final argument which
is where you drop the mic after about 10
or 15 seconds to make your point after
which i the judge jury and judy of this
show will have to make a decision do i
award the point to jake or to eric two
of my dear pal so here we go with binge
battle all about the final season of
better call saul and we start here with
round number one topic one going to jake
baldino a returning well not but
favorite here of the show
was the series finale good was it bad
was it okay was it possibly great or
terrible you have the floor for your
opening statement
i'm definitely going to go with great
i'm in a good position where i was going
into the finale not really hoping or
wanting an absolute blowout amazing
spectacle the show had already given me
so much that i was already satisfied so
my expectations weren't super high
but what they gave us i thought was
pretty great i think it checked it like
it cached all the checks that it wrote
throughout the entire show all the
setups with these characters it
solidified for me uh like i didn't
really realize it until the last episode
like a fantastic and kind of like
underrated low-key love story an
unconventional one uh a realistic one
despite all the larger than life stuff
that happens in this universe uh that it
really did hammer it all home for me
even if this wasn't an episode if at all
i still would have loved this show but
this was for me like a really good
cherry on top
all right well eric it seems like in
these days of online banking the last
time you hear cashing a check is about a
good tv show do you agree with your
buddy jake that it was great or do you
have a different opinion
i thought it was a good finale to the
breaking bad universe maybe a little
less so for better call saul i i happen
to watch with uh with someone a lot of
the episodes of this who didn't watch
breaking bad a little underwhelmed at
the end because it felt kind of like a
breaking bad thing more than anything
and she was like who's that who's that
you know uh so
i you know i i looked at it through that
lens even though i personally loved it
as a whole as a breaking bad universe
situation um i mean like imagine just
watching el camino what you know the
other thing is that i thought it was
surprisingly straightforward i think a
lot of people assumed he would wind up
in jail because yet walt died jesse got
away there's only one other thing that
we could do that wouldn't be the same as
the other two right uh so that was
relatively straightforward not
disappointing but like of course this
was gonna happen and um the only other
thing that i was thinking is that uh i i
also thought that the final season of
breaking bad was a little bit of a
downer in the sense that it felt more
like an epilogue this season the last
few episodes felt like an epilogue it
felt like it kind of ended before it
went to the gene times so it felt like a
big finale that i loved with the whole
lalo shootout and kim leaving and then a
little bit of an epilogue felt like a
like a hug goodbye so i'll go with good
that's an interesting point you bring up
because we do have later on in this
match uh another question that might
point towards what was your favorite
part of this season but if we're talking
about finale seems like we got a great
from jake and a good from eric so jake
back to you defending your position that
this was just more than a good finale
this was an all-timer
i think it was a final solidification of
the characters specifically
saul jimmy whoever whatever you want to
call him depending on the moment uh it
really understood that
it really kind of gave us like he really
is at the end of the day just a no-good
dirty rotten criminal but then it also
still solidifies at the very end
he's still in love with a person and he
that was enough to make a sketchy dude
ultimately still do the right thing and
that
just that just melts me like i am i am
the denzel giff like uh i just i love it
see us sketchy dudes can find true love
occasionally exactly uh let's go back to
eric eric and i'm also curious to see
here somewhere in your rebuttal how much
gentle nudging did you do with your
friend that maybe she needs to watch
breaking bad before better call saul was
there was there any sort of hey maybe
you checked the show out
it was actually my mom
my mom watched it because we were
watching it and she was like this seems
pretty cool and she kind of came in as
the show was starting but i kind of did
feel bad where in the last few episodes
i had to point this out every other
season it was like once in a while and
it was just a cameo this season it was
like the breaking bad stuff got more and
more important as it went on i don't
know if she's gonna go back and watch
breaking bad now because now she knows
like so many things of who dies and who
lives and stuff like that but look i
mean again i thought it was good it's
not that i thought it was bad or
anything but i will say i find to myself
when it ended um i was you know i just
it ended and i nodded sort of like just
in silence and then i found myself
looking up different like um easter eggs
and stuff like that that i didn't notice
connections that like from the beginning
of the show to the end or breaking bad i
found myself enjoying it more and more
as i looked into that stuff but the
finale itself just kind of was just kind
of like a silent nod for me
all right so we both liked it it's just
a question of how much what was the
temperature in the room so back to you
jake baldino you have the first closing
statement of the day
the temperature of the room for me was
emotion it takes a lot for a television
show to
make me get a little teary-eyed to make
me gasp at character moments and this
whole second half of this last season
did it and the last episode especially
not to mention the fact that
the last encounter
between
kim and jimmy is like low-key a very
sexy noir-tinged thing in a way that
like i feel like we haven't seen those
characters before but with everything
they've been through the fact that they
were in a relationship and here they are
meeting up years later once again
kim's hot again
jimmy's looking hot again because bob
odenkirk did mr nobody so he's like
jacked as hell and the lighting and the
cigarette and the little color on the
cigarette and and the heartbreak of it
but also the connection of it just
it made it fade to black and
just smile and like a little just a
little bit of a little bit of a little
bit of welling tears
yeah it felt a little bit like this
could be the start of a beautiful
friendship uh let's go to eric striffler
the final word in round one goes to you
uh my final word is content i was
content with it and i and i think i just
prefer to be
really wowed uh so again it's not even
it's not a bad thing so much as it was
just i was content you know what it
makes me think of the hearing jake talk
about it the well i guess i shouldn't
maybe cut this out if you have to do it
spoiler i'm sure everyone's seen an end
game the ending of end game it kind of
reminds me of that where it ends on that
kind of note that hearing jake talk
about it and i preferred it there it got
more got me more emotional there than it
did here here i was just sort of content
with it
it's so funny i knew i was going to have
to do a spoiler warning for better calls
than baby man i didn't realize avengers
end game was going to shoehorn its way
in there i have a strong feeling
everyone listening to this right now has
seen end game
well let's i mean you take you take
these two arguments and we're really
sort of splitting hairs here because you
both clearly liked the finale and you
loved the show when i think about the
finale i i think the the point that the
jake makes about that film noir feel and
i think that what what a great show like
this does is it makes us need the finale
even if you think the finale wasn't
necessarily the best finale you've ever
seen it became vital and we needed to
see what happened to these characters
and i feel like what happened to these
characters was warranted based on the
show that we just watched and enjoyed so
i feel myself leaning slightly towards
jake here although now we do have to
have eric and his mom have a binge
battle when they both catch up on
breaking bad so we'll put a pin in that
and for now jake baldino has the lead
one to nothing as we head into
round number two and your topic i think
it's one that eric might warm up to
based on his previous argument what's
the best episode in the final season you
can only take an episode from the final
season eric now a minute goes to you to
kick us off
uh so yeah my favorite episode of this
season without question is uh point and
shoot episode eight of the episode of
course where and this isn't necessarily
this shouldn't be counted but you have
to count it we had to wait to watch this
one right we had the incredible ending
with with howard getting shot and uh and
not and then we had a couple of weeks
just because of the scheduling thing so
the hype was unbelievable it was through
the roof and i i should say i am a
little biased on this because i got the
incredible experience of watching this
the premiere at the tribeca film
festival a couple weeks before it aired
on television so i got to see it with
great sound um and and the cast and crew
were there so the energy was was
electric in the room but i think i got
really lucky to watch that episode
because it was the best episode of the
season it's not so much that it was the
best episode because i got to see it
there i was very very happy what are the
chances that was the one i got to see
with a crowd um and i just thought it
was so exciting the music was
unbelievable the music nothing better
than that uh and uh and yeah that's to
me that's almost like
the finale or at least the beginning of
the finale because then the next episode
is kind of the finale as well so to me
that was the height of the season and
then it uh got a little uh sleepier not
bad because who doesn't like sleep got a
little sleepier after that got a little
aftermath denumati for you yeah like i
said it's kind of a uh
like an epilogue
all right so jake baldino do you want to
go an episode after eric or do you want
to pick from one of the earlier ones
yeah this is hard but i'm going to go
for the episode after eric episode 9 fun
and games because it just had a lot of
the tentpole things i like about the
show it had good gus stuff and it really
kind of wrapped up gus setting up what
would be his breaking bad empire but
then they also strengthened gus by
giving him one last darth vader moment
with him sitting at a bar chatting to a
nice handsome sommelier friend and
having a glass of wine and catching
himself
enjoying himself and then doubling down
like no i am gustavo and that just made
him so much cooler this show definitely
gave us a couple of little different
looks a little different
a couple of different sides to him that
i really appreciated also we got the
nacho mic arc wrapped up with mike
visiting nacho's father and
not really getting the encounter he was
hoping for but definitely the one that
he can handle with uh nacho's dad just
being like hey you guys are all the same
that just felt
right for that moment uh and then
the jimmy and kim lying
at howard's funeral is just another pit
of your stomach gut moment that i've
gotten throughout the entire show right
every single time that one of these
characters lied or scams you always go
ugh how much lower can they sink and
right at the end they sunk even lower
and then of course the two-hit combo of
the breakup at the end and then the
transition to
current better call saul in all his
glory with uh hookers and a gaudy
bedroom and it was just it was exactly
what we were waiting for but the show
really took its time for it
all right so back to you eric and let's
hear some specifics on why you think
episode eight may have been a little
better than episode nine in your opinion
so i'll give jake that all everything
you just said is great in episode nine i
loved all of that um like i said i feel
like those are kind of a one-two finale
almost in themselves but um
it's just it's just the thrill my heart
was racing um my heart was just like
pounding in my chest during during that
episode uh before that um so
that felt that just felt like the peak
it kind of reminds me of in season four
when uh with you know the explosion
right the explosion in the nursing home
and then there's just like a little bit
more after that i mean there's a whole
other season after that but um it just
you know it felt like that's the peak
for me that's what it reminded me of it
felt like that uh but i will say i just
want to say i do love also the gus thing
at the bar i thought that was beautiful
and and jake you also brought up that
that sort of sneaky encounter that
really got me on the edge of my seat and
i wasn't expecting it when mike was
talking to nacho's dad yeah that that
really cut deep and it worked uh mike
has been given so much in this show uh
and
for the last season we didn't really get
too much more a lot of that was wrapped
with his family and his past and stuff
like that but the end of the show gave
us just that little bit extra i also i
do agree with eric that the the previous
episode had that really good like vince
gilligan tension that breaking bad stuff
that we're all chasing but
i think with my episode episode nine man
it is so bold that instead of like oh
how is he gonna how is he gonna become
better call saul it wasn't him going
that's it today i'm going to become
better call saul no it skipped it it
time jumped the show was confident
enough in everything it's set up for so
long that it was like yeah we're just
gonna cut to him being that and it's
going to work because we gave you so
much i think that's super bold
storytelling and televisioning and i
love it for that
yeah i do like when art gets cocky
occasionally and we've seen instances
with better call saul doing that and it
usually pays off back to eric striffler
for his final argument here in round two
you know you just reminded me what my
final argument is if i'm thinking for
better call saul um my mom didn't fully
know what the hell happened at the end
when it went forward because she didn't
watch breaking bad so again thinking of
it only as better call saul that the
episode that i'm going for uh point and
shoot everyone watching better call saul
is completely on that that is the better
call saul episode and then once it gets
to nine it starts to slip into breaking
bad so i'm looking at it better call
solve versus breaking bad overall
universe and i think that's the better
better cause all episode i'd say that
five times fast by the way
impressive i i've i've never met someone
that can that can speak faster and more
eloquently than eric striffler but jake
baldino sometimes methodical makes some
good points you have the final say in
round two sir
uh i think really this episode was just
again
bold and it also gave little sprinkles
of everything we've been getting for the
entire show uh just human personal drama
cool breaking bad setups and then just
the the saul and all his scuzzy glory
payoff which really kind of oh it had an
aha moment when you think oh one day
we're going to wake up and we're never
going to remember this he told kim and
the theory for a lot of fans is
when he wakes up as saul
in his scuzzy beautiful home
that's the first day that he didn't
think of it and that is just
cinema
that's really really good stuff when i
think about these two episodes they
really work best as a companion piece so
so it's almost an evil plot that we're
making y'all pick between our two
favorite kids here but i look at eric
making the point that episode nine felt
a lot more like we're wrapping up not
just better call saul but breaking bad
it had a mountain to climb and i think
that it achieved it but if you're just
looking at an episode that really made
my pulse pound and really made me sort
of be like what this is this is arguably
the best episode not just this season
but possibly of the show itself
i would also look at at episode 8 just
because of what it did for better call
saul we can have the argument all day
that you need to watch breaking bad but
i thought the show
in its entire run did a magnificent job
of tying back to breaking bad but
allowing new viewers to get ingratiated
with better call saul first and then
maybe want to go on to see breaking bad
and i think that episode 8
point-and-shoot was the best example of
that so
by the narrowest of margins i got to
give striffer the point it's tied at one
to one and we move on to round number
three and we start back with jake
baldino and jake we're going to be
talking about all those moments that
wowed us that surprised us and it indeed
shocked us the most shocking moment of
the final season of better call saul is
what
lalo walking in and shooting howard was
incredible just an absolute mic drop
holy s just gasp amazing moment it is
perfect for lalo because he serves as
kind of like you know not to be too
reductive but like the joker of this
show he's just this crazy slick guy you
never know what he's going to do yet and
you kind of want to love him as
dastardly as he is and he pulls a
batgirl he opens the door ding dong pow
and it really really
worked it is terrifying it also is
super well sold by the actors on the
other side of it jimmy and kim are
horrified and that was like the craziest
acting they had done to that point where
it really felt like they saw a real
horrific thing for the first time and
you realize
oh yeah that this is the most despite
all the crazy things that go on this is
these this is the most traumatic thing
they had been exposed to at this point
and you realize that this is going to be
what kickstarts the beginning of the end
they
very much are seeing their mistake blow
up right in front of their face
yeah and and you know eric when you talk
about a surprising or even a shocking
moment given how
unhinged we know why would be that still
surprised the crap out of me so we need
a good moment from you now what do you
got the most shocking moment in the
final episode or the final season of
better call saul
first of all jake too soon to mention
batgirl uh but second of all um
second of all yeah my mo so look yes
shocking moment loved that moment that
to me was more of a heartbreaking moment
than a shocking moment because there was
no way that anyone was getting out of
that room you know what i mean like it
was shocking that it happened but at the
same time there was just no other thing
that could happen
what's really shocking is killing off
one of your main characters just a
couple episodes into your final season
and that's nacho shooting himself uh now
looking back it's telegraphed obviously
throughout the whole episode you know we
know what's gonna happen uh but we you
know you think he's gonna die but not
the way he did that was a moment that
was a jaw dropper that was a a true
literally let out a loud gasp moment
like a cartoon character um that
really took my breath away really
emotional heartbreaking i had to go back
well in fairness both scenes i had to go
back and watch again a couple times
which maybe makes me a psychopath but i
just went back and watched these people
dying that was one where yeah you
literally you're just watching and
you're waiting for what's gonna happen
and then no
huge reaction so i have to go with nacho
shooting himself yeah guy that always
seemed like he could figure his way out
of any jam and then to have that happen
uh let's go back to jake stumping for
wallow and howard
i think why i prefer mine is that i
wasn't as invested in the cartel nacho
stuff as i was the the rest of the story
i think it did a good job but i i think
for me it was really lalo shooting
howard and just kind of
how like i i kind of like by the end i
kind of liked howard you know he was
like another like this show does a
really good job of setting up kind of
antagonists that you then start to get
to know and then eventually things
change and you kind of like them and
they did that with howard and then uh he
gets he gets shot in the head and i
think it's really effective because he
was also at his absolute lowest what
they did to him what they dragged him
through
brought but the scene was already
unpredictable with him entering their
apartment it was already shocking for me
without lala walking in and shooting him
so it was really just amplified with
you know cool violence because that's
that's what we like
especially with a show like better call
saul uh back to you eric and just
talking about how nacho a man uh who is
at his wit's end who has no other plays
to make
so jake actually just once again kind of
what he just said made me realize
exactly what i'm what i'm thinking here
is that in that scene it's already
unpredictable because howard showed up
you're already on the edge of your seat
what's gonna happen you're already tense
and when it when it happens you get that
release with the nacho scene
i don't know maybe i'm wrong but i
wasn't like on the edge of my seat in
the same way i was pretty comfortable in
my seat i was all the way back in my
seat and uh because i was like ah you
know it's the beginning of the season
they're gonna get out of it they're
gonna figure it out oh my god so that's
why it's the more shocking moment for me
yeah it seems like you almost choked on
your bagel bite there when uh when that
happened because it's just so unexpected
uh to have it go down that way uh let's
go back to jake though it may be i mean
you're talking about an already
unpredictable scenario but even in that
it's a pretty big shock to everybody
when i was following it online as it
happened and it's like this surprised a
lot of people
i also just really like the actor he's
uh
slipping my tongue right now but the
actor who plays lalo is tony
thank you yes tony dalton is absolutely
incredible you just love to see him on
screen everything he's in he was
completely wasted in an mcu thing he is
stunning he's handsome he's incredible
he's sinister he's lovable and that
scene really gave him all of it you were
absolutely terrified by what he was
probably going to do but also you wanted
to hear what he had to say and you also
wanted to watch him do it and uh that
that makes it really just top tier for
me
uh eric's it's fun talking to you guys
about this show i haven't gotten to se
like this is the the finale like just
happened and so i haven't really been
able to talk about with anybody so this
is just fun for me to say this is one
you got to talk about this is a finale
that definitely requires a lot of
discussion yeah i'm just i'm bathing in
the glow of getting to finally talk
about this stuff eric you have the final
say here in round number three about
your most shocking moment
uh you know again it's just look yeah i
i once again i'm agreeing with jake on
this like yeah that was that was a big
shocking moment it's really just a
matter of when i think of shocking i
think of if i'm ready if i'm watching
fireworks i know the boom is coming you
know uh if if my car explodes i didn't
know the boom was coming and this felt
more like the uh like the ladder
i love that that might drop
i mean yeah you're you're expecting some
explosions on july 4th or where i live
in southern california july first and
second every night
yeah there's a lot of practice that goes
into fourth of july be safe out there
kids um as far as these fireworks that
we witnessed in the final season of
better call saul it's interesting that
you all picked uh a tony dalton
character and then a michael mando
character and i'll throw patrick fabian
in there as well i had the pleasure of
getting to interview a lot of them
leading up to this final season and you
could not i mean i was nervous to talk
to tony dalton and michael mando in
particular because i'd never met him
before could not be nicer fellas they're
so sweet then you watch him on better
call saul and you're like oh my god i
can't believe i was just in a room with
them michael is like a singer isn't he's
like a beautiful singer you never even
expect that they're all so so talented
and then you have these events unfold so
by the slimmest of margins again i do
have to go with eric's argument that you
just didn't see this coming in that way
for nacho with with wallow on screen and
particularly when you see the way lalo's
character and howard's character had
their stories go it was like an
immovable object versus an unstoppable
force and howard always so prim and
proper and buttoned up and then we see
what's unraveling with him and then
knowing that wow was getting more and
more unhinged it was something's bound
to happen i didn't see that coming i
never see anything like that coming but
it just felt like the nacho thing was a
bit more of a shock to me even though
both were crucial plot points going
forward so eric gets the point and he's
up two to one all of a sudden here we go
better call saul
season
the final season as it would be so now
we go on to round number four and we're
gonna start back with jake here jake i
want your take on the best character
that you saw in this season but we're
excluding saul
jimmy so anybody other than the namesake
of the show in your eyes who was the
best character throughout this season
the answer is simple it's kim wexler
i've been in love with her character
pretty much from the start because
there's so much to her and she is an
incredibly real character in a world
that can get a little zany a little over
the top and people can go in dark places
when she went to dark places it felt
like a real person and you could
absolutely understand it and
the whole thing with her with the whole
show the whole through line for me what
i really liked about her is is twofold
it's
the biggest thing really is that
with jimmy being with her it's kind of
like she is
i feel like we've all been in
relationships where the other person
inspires us to get our act together and
she absolutely was that in this show she
was kind of like the the anchor point
for him but on the other side she also
technically would kind of
cave into his schemes and ultimately
they kind of enabled each other to
become the worst versions of themselves
so it's tragic to see something that
works so well and doesn't and
you know when you couple that with
everything that she's had for this whole
show with her compelling arcs uh with
her lawyer stuff actually being
genuinely interesting i was hooked on
her from the beginning and i was the
most satisfied with where it went in
this season
yeah with better call saul i had no idea
i'd be that wrapped up in in warrior
stuff or like land deal negotiations but
it all really meant a lot uh let's go
back to eric striffler who's the best
character besides saul in your opinion
in this final season well you know it's
funny that you say besides saul because
i don't think saul's the best character
anyway i don't i don't know who would
pick him i think they've added a bunch
of other characters that are way more
interesting no offense to
saul but um uh so look you got you have
mike and gus they're breaking bad
characters they don't count right even
though they've had some incredible stuff
uh i find it impossible to pick between
kim lalo howard nacho you know like all
those characters they're all so good so
i'm gonna throw you a curve ball you
ready for this one i'm going with
marion
carol burnett's marion
wow
here's the thing didn't see her coming
had no idea and she wound up being the
one to really technically take down saul
goodman um i think she was incredible
from the moment we saw her i think she
really elevated like i said the sort of
sleepier last few episodes that epilogue
um and uh and she's it's just i mean
it's a testament to the creators of the
show of course that they could just make
any characters work so well but she was
uh i think just such a fun surprise and
so became so vital but didn't feel
shoehorned in like they gave her enough
time where it made sense that she was
the one to figure it all out in the end
and uh and so i'm going with marion wow
yeah i mean you're talking about the
most shocking moments in the history of
binge battle this is uh
this is really gonna rank up there but
yeah jeff's mother and uh you know i
don't know if she ever got to do one of
those ear-tug uh nods but uh it was
certainly uh just refreshing as a comedy
fan see carol burnett and uh desire in
that role was very interesting and a
little surprising so let's go back to
you jake baldino you didn't know you
were going against carol burnett in this
round but here we go it would be carol
burnett to take down bob odenkirk like
it is absolutely perfect
but uh kim i think
ultimately is the linchpin for the whole
show right up until the end where she
wraps up saul like where he was this
no-good dirty dude there was still a
a guy who isn't totally evil there i
guess someone who can't be redeemed can
still ultimately do the right thing and
i think he wouldn't have done that
without her and i just think that's
beautiful it's like poetry it rhymes and
the fact that she's just not the goody
two-shoes of the show but just the way
she worked out at the end where she went
to go do volunteer legal work
that scene with her walking in there i
didn't i didn't know what she was doing
i was like what is she is she seeking a
lawyer in this scuzzy place and then she
volunteered and i was like that made me
gasp of all moments someone applying for
a volunteer job that made me gasp
because it worked it was like of course
that's what she she was a civil defense
attorney she was defending anybody no
good anybody's off the street that was
her passion
and she's doing it once again she's
jumping into it because she has to
because she needs to and i
did that that was another moment where i
got a little teary-eyed
yeah and it's uh it's very inspiring for
no-gooders like me who hope to someday
have a free lawyer that is as good as
kim wexler so let's go back to eric for
your rebuttal here uh again you you
don't have as much screen time to kind
of pick and choose your moments from but
it was an impact seeing uh this
character and you're exactly right less
screen time stole the show mark
no look let's be clear jake's gonna win
this one kim is the best character on
the show but but but marion okay marion
also brought a tear to my eye because
she wanted to find a poor little nippy
okay uh no i i thought she was great i
yeah i i obviously agree with everything
jake's saying but uh i i still think
that yeah i think if we're thinking of
better calls all season six specific
characters that are new to this season
then technically marion should
win i love the the waving of the white
flag and then no no no wait never mind
i'm putting away i should win on a
technicality it wouldn't be right but i
should win
uh jake back to you for your final
argument where you can literally just
lick the stamp put it on an envelope and
mail it in if you need to most shocking
moment of the show was when marion hit
the life alert button and i was like
that's what that does there's a little
speaker in your home incredible that's
what product
i had no idea i'm sure now in in 2022
it's a little different but i was like
wow i think i want that just to have
somebody to talk to it's like onstar uh
but really kim
ria seahorn uh absolutely incredible and
one of the moments that really
solidified for me like the hook line and
sinker like get the award is you know i
don't think every scene where an actor
is yelling or shouting or crying is
worthy of
an award or praise sometimes it's more
of the subtle moments but i think her
finally breaking down on the airport
shuttle because i think we've all broken
down on an airport shuttle at least once
many times but to see that
long-lingering scene and it wasn't
necessarily of her convincingly crying
it was seeing her face work through
everything and her eyes dart around and
her process
maybe the entire show that really hit
you in the uh in the gut like a lot of
things in the show but
in a way that was different i just
i love kim
yeah it sort of reminded me of that
scene in um
unfaithful where diane landis has this
breakdown on the subway home because
she's trying so hard to do good and
she's done some bad things and it's just
it's all coming to a head really really
powerful stuff by ray seahorn there uh
eric striffler you have the final word
here you you sort of showed a lot of
your cards now do you have one more ace
in the hole stumping for marion
jeff gave his gr his mom his uh elderly
mom the internet and she's going to be
radicalized that's it
[Laughter]
that was all i could think i was like i
was waiting for her to be like you see
this coney guy we gotta find him
and that's it
even even if jake didn't have the
superior argument here i feel like i
would award him the point simply because
he said he wants a life call just so he
has somebody to talk to jake i'm gonna
get you one for your birthday okay you
never have to be alone again young man
yeah i love the idea of that being a
product placement by the way like
anyone's like shopping oh wow gotta get
that
hey you know the generation older than
y'all which i'm firmly in remembers the
i've fallen and i can't get up
commercial oh hell absolutely i love the
crucial part yes very very important
stuff there a life call a lifeful word
anything to talk to another human being
so now we have this two to two tie and
the only way to break it is our tie
breaker round this is the fifth and
final round and i don't think it's going
to be a problem for either one of you
creative minds here to put on your
thinking cap to get into your own little
writer's room and come up with the
better call saul character that deserves
their own spin-off this was a spin-off
of breaking bad so who gets the spin-off
of better call saul could be a show that
takes place in the future uh in the past
uh concurrently present
what say you
eric striffler
gotta die lyle
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm going with a lyle spin-off uh
because listen imagine being the manager
by the way lyle for anyone listening
lyle i should say is the character who
what is the manager i guess of of uh los
playos romanos because i'm sure
somebody's listening that like watches
the show but not like knows lyle um but
lyle i think uh being the manager of los
polos hermanos you've got
walter white coming in and harassing
your boss here at some point right in
the future maybe i guess you've got gus
calling in late whatever and then
showing up maybe with like a bulletproof
vest on at some point who knows i like
to imagine lyle fully knows what's going
on he knows exactly everything he's
smarter than anybody in the whole show
but he just chooses to keep his keep his
head down get his paycheck at the store
and and go home to uh who knows what
he's doing at home you think he's
playing video games you think he's a
criminal as well he's doing some kind of
crime crime
i want to know the point i want to know
more about lyle there you go gotta die
aisle the uh the actor is i believe
harrison thomas so it i guess you we
would say the assistant manager at los
poyos hermanos and it's even more
interesting then why is he seemingly uh
above
the manager on the call sheet
i feel like this is a show that i didn't
know i needed but now i do and so that's
a great opening from eric's trip with
jake baldino all of a sudden you got a
mound to climb here based on the
management goings on inside and outside
of los bleus ramonas what is your answer
for the character that deserves their
own spin-off i like the creativity with
eric uh and i was trying to think
creatively where i was trying to think
of like what zany characters have
appeared on the show like what what
character actually had enough weirdness
to them and it's lalo i'm once again
going to talk about lalo a lot but
again i think he's like the joker of the
breaking bad universe he is this
absolute wild card but i was really
thinking in terms of like what it can
add what it can provide where better
call saul ultimately added to breaking
bad and felt like a really good
companion piece i could see lalo in a
prequel just fleshing out some of the
cartel stuff because some of it for me
in better call saul were some of the
weaker aspects of the show i was the
least interested in that so i feel like
he could inject a little more to it
because when he did show up and when he
was really doing his thing it was the
best aspect of the cartel angle of the
show so for him to kind of have a
prequel thing where he's doing more of
those like weird dastardly things like
setting up a family to just be an
identifiable body for him to fake his
own death like just wild stuff like that
to just really giving a little bit more
of a strange zany lore to the salamancas
and everything i think there's a gap
that could be filled with lalo straight
up yeah he's he's so deviously mercurial
you can just never trust this person for
any stretch of time and so to see a show
play out like that would be certainly
unpredictable we could do a binge battle
just on the shocking moments in a show
about wallow but eric i am curious
you've peaked my interest it's you you
got my curiosity now you got my interest
with your show about the management at
los poyos fromanos look we don't know
what happens to lyle we know what
happens to lalo i'm done with the
prequels okay the prequels can go uh i'm
so i look i i cut uh the final season
some slack on being a little bit
straightforward because the final season
of better call solve course because they
have to work in the constraints of where
breaking pad starts and where it goes
and stuff right so i'll cut him some
slack i wouldn't cut him some slack on
another prequel though i'm done with it
i want to know where lyle goes from here
so we've done a regular show we've done
a prequel we have not done a concurrent
to breaking bad show that goes after
breaking bad we need eli lilo uh it's a
horrible outcome you know well i didn't
think that went ahead
so anyway um but uh i want we i think
running concurrent would bring back it
turns you know it's almost like it could
be like the end of a saw movie where it
like he shows up at the end of every
moment it turns out that like he was
actually behind it all along or
something where he showed up like gus is
not as good as he thinks so like imagine
gus when he um when he put the gun in
the uh in the meth lab right so he could
get lola that's one of those
straightforward moments by the way it's
like okay so that just played out like
we expected um imagine if like it wasn't
loaded gus screwed up lyle snuck in
because he knew he knew that gus had a
busy day at work and he went in and
loaded that gun so gus would live so i
think lyles may be pulling the strengths
you know speaking of prequels this
almost feels like that jar jar becomes
palpatine theory um
jake jake i'm gonna give you time to
really pitch us however you want to um
jake
you have a very interesting counter
argument here with eric and going for a
very minor character that could
potentially have an exciting backstory
and future
where do you go with the lalo show hang
on i'm kind of into the lyle thing
think about it
i'm sorry i'm so so think about lyle
where you know your boss calls you
because he got shot in the air you don't
know that but he calls you and says hey
i'm not gonna be in for a while i need
you to work all week and make the
schedule and the fact that he just went
okay sure
nope not no there's something there
that's not real he's got something going
on because that was i was like that's
that guy is as cold as gustavo fring so
there's something there anyway what was
i talking about is this a binge battle
first where the the opponent
actually takes the other side
uh the thing with lalo though where i
think it works is like think about what
we've gotten so far right we've gotten
saul goodman and we've gotten walter
white both in their own ways
hyper-intelligent highly capable people
and i think lalo fits that mold too
where i like these shows because clearly
the writers do like writing and coming
up with intricate little scams and weird
things and lalo is hyper intelligent
super capable he seems like he can
pretty much do everything so they would
have a lot of room to do some weird and
wild stuff
you have a lot of room uh eric again you
you really hooked me with this so
close the deal get the funding for this
show with your final statement
what's what's the uh is it the finale of
season three what it ends with uh with
with um jesse at the door right i think
that's the ending of season three oh
here we go um
that's ready final season of gotta die a
lot
gotta die lyle knock knock knock on the
door
lyle's standing out there he's got a
loaded gun and he's pointing at the door
who opens the door jesse
cut to black
wow okay i mean
but i mean
yeah maybe no no it's jesse but then
huel leans in you know like in the
shining when the bear leans up so the
door opens and it's jessie's sitting
there
the bear gets up and looks over in it's
fuel and then a gunshot cut to black
just i mean he pretty much had us at the
show gotta die oh um
jake baldino
you you have the floor for the final
argument in this show for the win do you
want to just go with me over to eric's
place and watch gotta die a while or do
you have one more shot in the lalo
chamber i came up i came up here with
all my college credits trying to talk
about proper writing and character
building and
gotta dial isle is
that's it man i concede
incredible
for the record i would probably have to
give the point to a wow show because i
think that's more viable this is an
executive but look jake and eric seem to
be in agreement that we gotta know he's
forfeited yeah
it's just too intriguing because not
just the goings on at lowe's players
hermanos but also want to know what
happens like in what does the guy do
when he's off what's his home life like
who's he supporting does he have pets he
probably has like an iguana or a parrot
or some sort of off-brand kind of pet we
need to know more about it so tune in to
gotta die a while and then we're gonna
have eric and jake back after that joe's
finale to debate the merits of it so
um by process of elimination eric
striffler is your winner today yes
he i'm so pretty so proud two-time loser
jake baldino that's how i want to be
that's it i mean excellent work jake i
was ready to give you the win but then
eric comes in here uh let's not forget
his last two characters he was stumping
for were marion and lyle and he somehow
gets the w here but you're both number
one in the viewers hearts and that
really is all that matters at the end of
the day eric striffler our new champion
here on binge battle uh you get the four
first where can all the kids find you
what sort of stuff you're working on now
uh if you liked how i wrapped this up by
acting like a jackass and coming out on
top you're going to want to go and watch
pretty much it on youtube
you go to youtube.com pretty much it you
can find everything from there that's
where we post highlight videos for our
full commentary tracks that we do for
movies and tv shows and we will be doing
a series of commentary tracks forgot to
die a lil
as one would hope and i hope that uh you
and your mom enjoy that program together
is there another show that you're
currently enjoying that you're currently
binging or something out there in the
world that you want to shed some light
on that you think everybody out there
watching this show should check out oh
yeah and i'm sure jake will pro i hope
jake's been watching i'm sure he'll
agree uh the finale of the rehearsal
nathan fielder's uh new show is is this
friday so you gotta i mean catch up on
it it's really easy to catch up on in
the finale well i don't know when this
is coming out but the finale is when
coming up when we're recording this uh
but you can probably binge the whole
show and it's worth it six episodes yes
i've heard nothing but great things
about that jake you co-signed that
streaming recommendation yes one of the
greatest apocalypto references i've ever
heard in my life
am i gonna get lost watching that show
it feels a little intimidating for some
reason am i gonna be confused or lost or
is it just pretty easy entry point first
episode sets you up perfectly i think it
explains exactly what it is and you
don't need to watch nathan for you if
you watch nathan for you you'll
understand his humor right off the bat
but i think you'll get it watching the
first episode
all right then uh jake baldino where can
all the kids find you you have your own
youtube channel that i just you just go
to youtube and search your name right
yep uh jake baldino on youtube i talk
about video games and movies and stuff
i'm also on game ranks every day who
gets more friends per second is that
going to be wild or is that going to be
jake
definitely lyle lyle gets
i was going to say babes per second
definitely but we don't know his uh
orientation so that's fine so you said
you have technically three friends on
there which one of them is only a
technical friend in your mind oh i mean
they're all yeah okay don't do this
don't divide us all right
you brought it back around i got them i
got it it's new can we not do this yet
can we not break it
i love watching my friends from from
pretty much it from youtube just run
circles around each other mentally and
it's been a hoot here on binge battle to
have eric striffler and jake baldino our
two special guests here for them
christian rule comma our expert engineer
i am merely mark ellis reminding y'all
to check out rotten tomatoes and
rottentomatos.com for all the latest in
the world of tv movies and everything in
between if there is a green light forgot
to die a while rottentomatoes.com is
going to be your place to check out all
the latest updates with it for everybody
here at binge battle thanks for tuning
in we'll see you next time
bring it on